แต่ร้านนี้ดู
Two  Way สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียน Body ทุกคนถ้า
กูตั้มคะคูเอกกับคุณต้อมก็มาเจอกันนะคะคะ
ๆเจอกันในวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
คุณเอ๋วันพุธนะคะเดี๋ยวคุยเขียนให้เปิด
วันพุธๆๆๆๆ
วันพุธนะคะผมพูดสักครู่นะคะคุณต้อมให้
ซื้อ put อยากได้สีเขียวผู้หญิงจะไปคุย
เอาวันอังคาร
เถ้าสีชมพูวันอังคาร
เอาใหม่
ขอโทษค่ะคุณสีเขียว
วันพุธหาเนื้อที่
กไก่คะ
22 ค่ะ
22 เดือนอะไรคะ
มิถุนายนเดือนมิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะมีพ.ศ
2565 คา
2565 ผชอะไรคะ
2022 ค่ะ
วันนี้เวลากี่โมงคะกรุ่นตอนนี้
21:05 เขว 9:00 นชานทีครูต้อมกับครูเอ๋
ก็ต้องพูดจนถึงกี่โมงคะกี่ทุ่ม
3 ทุ่ม 35 นาทีค่ะ
09:30  5 นาทีนะคะ 20 นาทีนะคะนะถ้าเรา
ก็จะพูดตั้งแต่
09:00 น 5 นาทีนจนถึง 21:00 น 3  15
นาทีนะคะนี่คู๋ลบก่อนนะคะคุณต้อม
คลิปนี้กูต้องอยากจะคุยอะไรกับครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ครูต้อมอยากจะถามผู้ a ว่าครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบ
จัดงานวันเกิดไหมคะงานวันเกิดเหรอคะ
[เพลง]
ครูเอกคนไทยแล้วก็ต่างจังหวัด
อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะกรุงเทพฯซื้อ
กรุงเทพฯ
คู๋และอยู่ต่างเอาไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรเห็น
คู๋อยู่ที่นี่ชลบุรี
ชลบุรีแล้วก็มีเวลาคุยเด็กๆอ่ะไม่มีวัน
เกิดมีแต่ว่า
ที่บ้านไม่มีวันเกิดแตกๆเวลาครูเอกเข้ามา
กรุงเทพฯอ่ะมีนะวันเกิดวันเกิด
วันวันเกิดก็จะต้องไปเค้กใช่มั้ยคุณต้อม
เนี่ยให้คู๋มีวันเกิดค่ะกลัวกูต้องเอา
ครั้งแรกหรือครั้งสุดท้ายเอาของกูเอง
ครั้งแรกก่อนครั้งแรกหรอ
วันเกิดครูเอ๋ครั้งแรกอายุยี่สิบยี่สิบปี
ไหม
อ๋อก็ครึ่งปีที่แล้วนี่เองน้องๆครับ
แล้วเออ 3  32 ปีที่แล้วไอ้สัยผมแหม
อย่างนี้อย่างนี้แหละเล่าให้ฟังนิดนึงได้
กูซ่อมตอนนั้นอ่ะครูเอ๋ทำงานที่เรือ
มีเรือนะคะเรือ
เป็นเขาเรียกอะไรนะเป็นขลุย
ถูกมั้ยเนี่ยรู้แล้วเรือไปเที่ยวค่ะเรือ
ใหญ่แล้วก็เรือมี 7 ชั้น
เป็น Titanic เลยเหรอใครๆไททาเนตก็ไป
ภูเก็ตไปเกาะสมุยไปเที่ยงในทะเลแล้วทำงาน
ที่นี่ตั้งแต่อายุ 19
9 แล้วก็ไปถึง 21 น่ะคู่เอกก็คิดคลิป
เนี้ยสุดท้ายนะบ๊ายบาย
ไม่ทำงานที่เรือแล้วแปลงคิดงั้นน่ะเป็น
วันเกิดครูเอ๋นอ่าวันเกิดคุยอ่ะแล้วก็จะ
ไม่จำจะไม่ทำงานเชฟ
เชฟที่เรือน่ะ
เทปนะคะต้องบอกแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะค่ะหนู 0
สูงๆเนี่ย
หมวกขาวทำไมคุยว่าสิบโอเคอ่า
เท Pop คนไทยก็พูดเป็นเชฟเลยนะภาษาอังกฤษ
ในล่ะค่ะ
รักคนนี้ค่ะคนที่ผู้ชาย
แล้วก็ใส่มั่ว
เงา
คนเนี่ยมันไทยมันดีก็พูดว่าพ่อครัวก็ได้
นะกูเอ๋เนาะที่เรือเขาจะมี Cape แล้วก็มี
พ่อครัวอ๋ออ๋อมีสองอย่างเลย High เชฟน่า
จะจะแบบลิ้นดีมาก
แล้วก็คิดทำอาหารได้รถเชฟทำอาหารอร่อยมาก
ๆ
จะเห็นว่าตอนหลังเชฟออก
ไม่อร่อยอ้าเอา
สูตรดีนะเหมือนเดิมนะแต่ไม่รู้เช็คมี
เทคนิคอะไรนะคะ
ก็เทมนะทำอาหารเก่งมากอร่อยมาก
ก็เป็นเชฟจริงๆเขาเรียนก็ทำอาหาร
ญี่ปุ่นอาหารอิตาลีอิตาลีอ่ะอาหารจริงได้
หมดนะครับผ่านเทปก็เลยทำเค้กให้ครูเอ๋คุณ
ต้องว้าว
กูเอกก็เลยได้
งานวันเกิดครั้งแรก
งูอันนั้นคืองานวันเกิดจริงๆครูเอ๋ก็ไม่
มีอีกนะหมอมันเป็นงานวันเกิดที่มีเค้กมี
ไม่มีไม่อยู่เลยเหรอนะ
ถ้าพรุ่งนี้ไม่มีๆเอาแต่ไม่เคยทำเองก็มี
ล้อมีนักเรียนทำมาเป็นครูมีนักเรียนมี
เค้กมาให้อ๋อ
มีเค้กมาให้ครั้งสุดท้าย
ครั้งสุดท้ายของวันเกิด
น่าจะอายุประมาณ
เท่าไหร่คะ
30 กว่าๆใกล้ๆสีสิกข
30 กว่าๆนะคะคือคือนักเรียนที่ครูเอกจำ
ไม่ได้เพราะว่ามันนานแล้วเนาะ
ประมาณสิบกว่าปีที่แล้วอ่ะครั้งสุดท้าย
คุณต้องน้องสุดท้ายหรือว่าครั้งล่าสุดได้
ไหมครูเอ๋
น่าจะครั้งสุดท้ายนะคะไม่สิเดี๋ยวปีนี้
เดี๋ยวคุณต้องจัดเค้กไปให้กูเอ๋
คือขอโทษนะคือกูเองไม่ชอบมีงานวันเกิด
พม่า
แต่ว่าเออไม่ไม่รู้คือถ้าวันเกิดอ่ะครู
เอกจะคิดถึงคุณแม่
เอ๋ไม่ๆชอบไปปาร์ตี้วันเกิดตัวเองอ้าว
งั้นเกิดเนี่ยอยากกลับบ้านแล้วก็ทำอาหาร
ลำให้คุณแม่กินน้อนอนเยี่ยมมากเลยก็เลยก็
เลยคุณตั้มเฮ่ยทำไมเอ๊ะจำวันงานวันเกิด
ไม่ได้เพราะว่าเอ๋มีความคิดอันนี้
อยู่กรุงเทพฯก็เลย
ไม่มันขี้หลานหลานก็บอกว่าอ้ะกินข้าวกิน
ข้าววันเกิดแต่ว่าวันเกิดผ่านไปแล้ว 2
เดือน
นานมากๆก็เลยก็เลยไม่ค่อยได้มีวันเกิดแต่
ของน้องมีทุกปีไหมคะครูต้องเด็กๆเมื่อ
ก่อนนะคะตอนเด็กๆมีเนื้อหาอาคุณพ่อกับ
คุณแม่คุณปู่คุณย่าอาเยอะแยะเลยมุกคนใน
บ้านชอบจัดวันเกิดห่อผ่านวันเกิดมีขนม
เค้กให้ทุกๆปีกุดต้องแปลว่าคุณต้องเป็น
หลานรัก
พ่ายหลานรักกรุ๊ป B เลยทำให้ครูต้องชอบ
เค้กวันเกิดมากชอบคุณแม่คุณปู่คุณย่า
คุณยายคุณพลคุณอาคุณอาอาอาหารจำได้คุณอา
เป็นผู้ชายใช่ไหมอ้าวคุณอาไม่ลุงคุณลุง
ตาย
คุณน้าอ่าเดี๋ยวไปหมดคุณต้อมๆนี้
วันเกิดขอให้ทุกๆปีแล้วก็จะมีเพื่อนๆมา
ปาร์ตี้กันยิงง่วงก็ชอบปีนี้บางบางปี
สมมติปีหนึ่งไม่จ้ะอ่ะกูต้องก็จะเสียใจ
งูน่าสงสารจังเลยเห
รอเนี่ยเอาคุณต้นโตขึ้นนะคะเพราะคุณต้อง
โตขึ้นเป็นผู้ใหญ่เนี่ยผู้กูต้องก็เลยคิด
ว่า
ถ้าเกิดกูต้องมีลูกท่องจะ
ไม่ไม่จะวันเกิดเยอะยิ่งใหญ่ไม่จัดฟัน
เกิดเยอะๆไม่ทำใช่ไหมให้จัดแบบเล็กๆๆ
ไม่ต้องเป่าเค้กเป่าเค้กอันเล็กๆค่ะเอา
เครปเอาผลไม้ฮู๋เอาแตงโมมาฝากเทียน
ทุเรียน
เอาไก่ไก่ทอดร้านเคเอฟซี
ปักเทียนก็คือเป็นเฉพาะพ่อพ่ออันนี้เอา
ออกเนาะคุณมองว่าถ้าเป็นวันเกิดของรูปอา
เป็น
มีพ่อ
แม่อันนี้สิต้อม
แล้วก็ลูกชายใช่ไหมคะ
3 คนพอแล้วพอแล้วเล็กๆบ้านยาย 1 คนได้
ไหมคะคุณยายได้คุณยายได้
ก็ got จะเล็กๆเพราะมาก่อนใหญ่ๆทาย
ของครูเอ๋แรกก็อย่างที่บอกไม่มีแล้วเวลา
มีคนให้เค้กวันเกิดทำตัวไม่ถูก
โอเคไงตัว
คือจริงๆนะทุกวันนี้ก็เป็นถ้าเกิดว่าแบบ
เอ๊ยมีแฟนอ่ะอ่ะ
สุขสันต์วันเกิดครูเอกเจ้า
ไม่รู้จะทำยังไงดีไม่
รู้ทำตัวไม่ถูก
มั้ยหรืออะไรเขาเต้นเออคือไม่เป็นคนไม่
ได้รอไงไม่ได้หรอกงานวันเกิดพอมีฮักเกิด
พี่เอ๋ตกใจค่ะไม่ให้ตื่นเต้นตกใช้สภาพภาย
นี่ไม่ค่อยชอบอะไรที่เสริมอะไรไม่ชอบ
เซอร์ไพรส์ชนะ kuai ดูรูปนี้อีกรูปนึงนะ
ลูกต่อไปเนี้ยเนี่ยพูด
ไว้อีกวันเกิดก็ต้องมีเป่าเทียมใช่ไหมกู
เอ๋ก็ต้องมีเทียนแล้วเทียน 1 เล่ม
กับอายุราว 1 ปีเจนและถูกต้องรอเดี๋ยวนะ
คะ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11  12
13  14  15  16  17  18  19  20  4  21
22  26  14  25  o มีรูปเนี้ย 25
น่าจะนะไม่ผิดนะมีใช่มีเทียน 25 เล่ม
เราคิดว่าอายุ 1 ปี = เทียน 1 เล่มเวลา
ที่เราอายุมากขึ้นต้องมีเทียนมากขึ้นแล้ว
เดี๋ยวคุณต้อมแล้วในนี้มีเขียน 25 เล่ม
อายุเท่าไหร่คะอันนี้ไม่ใช่ลูกของครูต้อง
นะเป็นรูปจาก Internet ค่ะอันนี้กูต้อง
คิดว่าเขาอายุ 24 ปีค่ะพี่ถ้าเป็นคนไทย
น้องก็จะอายุ 24 แต่จะมีเทียนน่ะ 25
อ้าเป็นความเชื่ออีกค่ะนักเรียนเพราะว่า
จะคุณ 24 แล้วมีเขียน 24 แปลว่าไม่มีปี
หน้า
ดังนั้นเขาบอกว่าอ้ออ่ะ 4  24 ก็จะมี
เทียน 25
บวกเข้าไปอีกหนึ่งจะได้แข็งแรงถึง 25 ไป
ค่ะก็เขาเชื่อแบบนั้นนะคะ
เพราะผู้หญิงคุณต้อมนะอายุเยอะขึ้นน่ะกู
ต้องก็ไม่จัดแล้ววันเกิดทำไมวะเฮียนเยอะ
เกินไปปากไม่ไหวละเค็มกูต้องเต็มเค้กไป
หมด
เทียนจนมองไม่เห็นเค้กแล้วค่ะ
กูต้องจากแสงเค้กใหญ่ขึ้น
ต้องเป็นเพียงแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
อันใหญ่ๆแล้วมีชั้น 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3
หรือว่าเค้กใหญ่ไรก็เต็มโต๊ะแล้วก็ปัก
เทียน
ก็มีเทคนิคอันนึงเขาก็บอกและก็คิดว่า
เทียนหนึ่งแล้ว
เข้ากับสิบปี
[เพลง]
อย่างของเราก็เทียน 6 เล่ม
เออเราลบสิบปีออกไปก่อน
คำถามเทียนเล่มเทียน 6 เล่มครูอายุเท่า
ไหร่อ๋อ
คิดมัน 5 ค่าครึ่งไม่ได้ไงก็ต้องใช่มั้ย
ก็ต้อง 6  S  55  16 มะ
คิดอายุครู
ไม่ต้องคิด
ครูอายุเท่าไหร่อ่ะเอาหน้าหน้าครั้งสุด
ท้ายจำอายุตัวเองไม่ได้และ
จำไม่ได้เลยให้หาดีนะกู a ดูรูปนี้นี่
ค้างล่าสุดกูต้องได้เป่าเค้กอีกแล้วโอ๊ย
เทียนกินแล้วก็เอกขอดูก่อน 1  2  3  4  5
6  7  9 หรือเปล่าครูต้อมด้าวเล่มอนิด
ทั้งล่าสุดนะคะเมื่อปี
2000  2010
88 พร้อมมิเทียนอ่ะ 9 เล่มอันนี้เป็น
เพื่อนๆที่ทำงานครูต้อมๆเดี๋ยวกูตั้มขยาย
เทียนให้เห็นครบ 9 ไม่ 9 ไหมก๋วยเตี๊ยว
เดี๋ยวหน้าก่อนกูอ่ะกูอ่ะดาววะ 9 นะคะจะ
ได้จะได้ไม่ต้องคิดอายุ 1 จำไม่ได้คิดว่า
9 เลยสี่ห้าหกเจ็ดแปดเก้าสงกรานต์อะหนัง
สีมันเหลืองเก้าสิบ
เก่งมาก
อันนี้ก็ไม่เหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียนและหลัง
จากหลังจากอายุ 30 เนี่ย
30 ขึ้นไปแล้วนะข้าไม่อยากคิดไม่ว่าคิด
ไม่อยากคิดอายุ
หัวกูเองมีเทคนิคคิดนะกูต้องเป็นยังไง
อายุเท่าไหร่ปีนี้ออกบอกว่าผู้หญิงนะพอ
อายุไปจนถึง 30 จะยูเทิร์นกลับค่ะ
ตอนนี้ครูเอกก็อายุเท่าไหร่แล้วเนี่ยอายุ
6 ปีเดี๋ยวเค้ายูเทิร์นกลับมาเลย 6 ปี
อีก 6 ปี 60 ค่ะ
6 ปี 60 ใช่ไหมตอน 30 แล้วก็ย้อนกลับมา
ที่ศูนย์ไหม
เนี่ยกูอ่ะรู้ไหมรูปเนี้ยกูต้องอ่ะไม่คิด
ไม่ได้คิดว่าน้องๆที่ทำงานทุกคนถ้าจะเอา
เค้กมาเซอร์ไพรส์วันเกิดเรา
กูต้องอ่ะ
น้ำตาจะไหลอ่ะร้องไห้รอยอ้าแต่ว่าคุณต้อง
ยังชอบงานวันเกิดชอบเข็ม
ทองที่ครูต้องหมายคิดว่าตัวเองหรอกไม่
เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรก็มีเค้กก็ได้โอเคจะพอกู
ต้องชอบให้เค้กคนอื่นให้เค้กเพื่อนให้
เช็คน้องให้เค้กลูกคุยก็ช่องให้ค่ะแต่กู
เองไม่ช่องไม่ชอบมีคนให้ใช่เพราะพองมีคน
ที่ทำงานเพื่อนที่ทำงานเอาเค้กให้อ่ะแล้ว
ก็แบบเสื้อผ้าคล้ายติดไฟด้วยนะปิดไฟอาญา
อ้ายปิดไฟมืดเลยค่ะแล้วก็ Happy  Birthday
To  You คุณต้องหลบ
ร้องไห้อายุตรงมาเหลือ 15 เฮ้ย
เฮ้ยเวลาหมอดีใจมากดีใจที่น้องเขารักเรา
หนูน้ำตาไหลร้องไห้เลย
อันนี้คือครั้งสุดท้ายหรือข้างหลังของล่า
สุด
ครั้งล่าสุดก็คือหลังแจก 2018 ไม่มีเค้ก
อีกนะคะยังไม่มีค่ะ
คิดว่าปีนี้จะมีเคสค่ะคู๋มีนี้กูต้องจะไป
ซื้อเค้กมาให้ตัวเอง
ส่วนแพ่งคนดีมาตบใครตัวเอง
จะไปซื้อเค้กที่เป็นอะไรครีมหมีอยากกิน
มากเลยกูต้องชอบเค้กไอศครีมหรือว่ารูปชอบ
คะกูต้องก็ชอบลูกก็ชอบแต่ถ้ากูเอง
แต่ครูเอ๋รู้ไหมคะตอนที่อ่าเวลาเราโตเป็น
ผู้ใหญ่เนี่ยเราจะคิดว่าไม่ต้องมีเค้กได้
ไม่ต้องมีของขวัญก็ได้เราอ่ะอยากจะเป็นคน
ขวัญของขวัญของขวัญพูดว่าของขวัญนี้ขอ
เกาะคุณต้อมขอลาว่างๆได้ไหมค่ะก่อนว่างๆ
เอาหน้าเนียนหน้ามีอ่ะ
ของขวัญก็คืออันนี้
มีกล่องเนาะ
กล้องนะคะ
แล้วก็ริบบิ้นสีชมพูแล้วกัน
อันนี้ก็เอกชอบมาฆ่าเอ๋อิน
ชอบไปซื้อเองขอซื้อของขวัญขอให้ตัวเองได้
อันนี้บ้าบ่ๆนะคะนักเรียน
ไปซื้อนะครับขอของขวัญด้วยค่ะแต่เขาเอาบ่
แล้วเอากลับบ้านซื้อกับที่ของขวัญวันเกิด
ตัว
นี้โอเคนะน่ารักดีอ่ะ
หลับตาไม่ได้เป็นทุกปีนะคะเราจะซื้อมานะ
แกะและนะ
ให้ตัวเองค่ะ
ครั้ง
มีนะกู a เนาะบางคนก็ซื้อของขวัญให้ตัว
เองเป็นแบบโทรศัพท์ถือว่าเป็นหูฟังที่แบบ
ราคาแพงๆอ่ะพี่เอ๋กอล์ฟปีละ 1 ครั้งให้
รางวัลกับตัวเองกูเอ๋ให้ตัวเองตอนอายุน่า
จะ
25 มาประมาณ 20
22 นะค่ะจนถึงสิบประมาณเนี้ยมินิกส์น่า
สนุกดีเหมือนกันดังมีความเบื่อละไม่ทำ
แล้วไม่เล่นแล้วๆเพราะว่าก็อย่างที่บอก
ที่บ้านไม่ได้สอนไม่ได้ไม่ได้ทำไว้ให้
ก็เลยไม่ไม่มีจำว่าต้องมีแต่กูต้องชอบ
เวลาแกะของขวัญให้ชอบชอบมันตื่นเต้นตื่น
เต้นจะได้อะไรนะจะได้อะไรนะแล้วเวลาเด็กๆ
เวลาเปิดของขวัญเด็กแกะของขวัญออกมาว่าดี
ใจทุกกล่องเลยฮะ
ดีใจดีใจทุกกล่องเลยค่ะเพราะตอนเด็กๆอ่ะ
เวลาเปิดของขวัญน่ะทุกๆกล่องจะเป็นของ
เล่นเป็นตุ๊กตา
ตุ๊กตาตัวเล็กๆ
กูต้องกับคนนางเอกเขาเบรคนิดนึงกูต้องได้
หยิบคืนคืนไหมกูเองได้ยินใช่ไหมไม่ของเอ๋
อ่ะ
แก้คำพูดของคุณต้อมฟ้าร้องเหมือนกันตัว
เอกก็ฟ้าร้องครืนบ้านกูต้องกลับบ้านกูเอก
ใกล้ๆกันนะคะ
ประมาณ 5 กิโลเมตรได้มั้ยๆนะคุยร้อง
มีฟ้าร้องแต่กูต้องไม่ได้ยินจากของเอ๋ไป
ใช่ไหมไม่ครูต้องได้ยินที่บ้านโอเคโอเค
มันก็มึงเป็นกำลังจะมีเมฆมันจะมีฝนตกมี
แม่แล้วก็จะมีคือๆ
เริ่ม
ถ้ามีเสียงเข้าไปขอโทษนะคะนักเรียน
เอานี้ที่กรุงเทพฯฝนตกทุกวันค่ะอ๋อได้
กลัวเสียงเข้าไปก็เลยเช็คกับกูต้องว่ามี
เสียงจากที่นี่ไหมถ้าไม่มีโอเคราคาเสียง
จากครูเอ๋ไม่มีแต่มีเสียงจากครูต้องบอก
ไม่มีไม่มีกูเองไม่ได้ยินใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
พี่ยัตต่อกันครูเอ๋จะหมดเวลาแล้วคุณต้อม
ก็เลยคิดว่าเวลาวันเกิดนะค่ะไม่เอาของ
ขวัญไม่เอาขนมเค้ก
ต้อมมีค่ะขอโทษค่ะพระ
สาธุขอโทษขอโทษขอโทษ
ใส่บาตร
อ๋ออ๋อดีมากกูต้อง
เนาะวันเกิดเราเราทำบุญดีกว่าเนาะกูต้อง
คิดว่าใส่บาตรแล้วจะดีๆสบายใจนะคะสมัคร
ให้
ครูเอ๋ใส่บาตร
ครั้งสุดท้าย
เมื่อไหร่คะหนู
อ่านมากเลยหรอนานมาก 2020
[เพลง]
เมื่อสองปีนึงว่าอ๋อนี่ลูกในคุณต้องไปใส่
บาตรเมื่ออาทิตย์ที่แล้วนี่เองหึคือใส่
บาตรแบบนี้นะคะใส่บ้างตอนเช้านอนแล้วก็
ตื่นแล้วก็ไปซื้ออาหารแล้วก็ใส่บาตรที่
มากเดินเดินบิณฑบาตระบบพระเดินบิณฑบาตร
ครูต้อมเนี้ยใส่บาตรหรือปลักบาทนะคะ
อันเนี้ยตั้งแต่ 2  0  2  0  2 ปีค่ะแต่
วันนี้ที่วัดไปที่วัดอ่าไปที่วัดก็ประมาณ
มกราคมค่ะมกราเคย
มกราคมไม่ใช่
มกราคมมกราคมเดือน 6 เดือนแล้วก็ไปใส่
บาตรทางล่าสุดทำบุญเหมือนกันค่ะแต่ว่า
ออนไลน์มา
ถ้าไม่ใช่บาทนานมาก
โควิชไม่ได้ไปเดินแล้วก็ตักบาตรเลย
อิจฉาเพื่อนเพื่อนๆตักบาตร
ก็อนุโมทนาค่ะสาธุค่ะใช่ไหมให้ไม่ได้
สาธุแล้วก็จะได้ดีๆค่ะดีมีเงินดีๆ
แข็งแรงนะพี่เอ๋ถ้า
ผู้ตามก็เปลี่ยนจาก
ฉลองเราได้ฉลองวันเกิดตายนะคะวันเกิดบาท
วันเกิดค่ะวันเกิดที่เป่าเค้กครั้งสุด
ท้ายก็ 2018 ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วจะครูต้องคิดจะมีอีกไหมอ่ะแต่คุณต้อง
กินว่าจะมีนะครับปีเนี้ยขอให้แสดงว่าไม่
ใช่ขันสุดท้ายใช่ครั้งสุดท้ายเป็นครั้ง
ล่าสุดครั้งล่าสุดครั้งล่าสุดแปลว่าหยุด
แต่จะมีอีกแต่ถ้าเราบอกว่าครั้งสุดท้ายก็
คือไม่มีแล้วเธอจะไม่มีแล้วไม่ไปแล้วไม่
ทำแล้วนะคะอันนี้ครั้งสุดท้ายนะคะกลับ
บ้านเคลียร์กูต้องคนไทยก็พูดครั้งสุดท้าย
แต่ยังไม่สมหายแต่ไม่สุดท้ายเอ่อก็ต้อง
พูดครั้งล่าสุดแล้วไม่พูดครั้งล่าสุดพูด
ว่าครั้งสุดท้ายนะคะมันครั้งสุดท้ายที่
ที่เป่าเค้กฮาอย่า
2018 จริงๆไม่ใช่สุดท้ายล่าสุดยังมีอีก
ใช่มะยังมีอีกค่ะเอ๋น่ากินกุ้งกินต้มยำ
กุ้งอีกครั้งตอนอายุ 35
ต้มยำกุ้งนะเอกคิดอีกไหมคะ
ไหมไม่กินทำไมคัน
แพ้กุ้งกุ้ง
ภาณีก็เลยเป็นครั้งสุดท้ายจริงๆก็คือไม่
กินกุ้งเลย
ก็สามีคู๋ก็กินกุ้งครั้งสุดท้าย
ครั้งสุดท้ายที่เขาสั่งแล้วกินเองน่าจะ
อายุประมาณ
[เพลง]
ครั้งสุดท้ายนะอันนี้สุดท้ายจริงๆเพราะ
เกรงไม่กินแล้วเวลาเขาสั่งต้มยำกุ้งมา
แล้วไอ้กินตุ้มจะกินน้ำสุดเลยทันอ๋อเขาก็
เลยไม่กินกล้วยทิศ
EP
สามีน่ารักมากร้านอาหารกานิครั้งสุดท้าย
นัดสุดท้ายจริงๆนะคะอะไรค่ะกูต้อมเรา
เรียกว่าครั้งล่าสุดใช่ไหมทางล่าสุดค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ข้างล่าสุดสำหรับเป่าเค้กน่ะ 2018
I ค่ะแล้วก็จะวิธีเมื่อไหร่ไม่รู้โอเค
ถ้าอย่างนั้นเนี่ยนะคะอันนี้คือครั้งต่อ
ไป
เขียนกี่เล่มค่ะคิดว่าจะไม่ปัดเคลียร์
แล้วค่ะโอ้ใช่ตอนนี้ห้ามปักไม่ต้องปาก
แล้วค่ะปวดหัว
ปวดต้องเปล่าเดี๋ยวทุกคนเอาไม่กินใช่ใช้
มือพัดพัดพัดพัดเทียนไม่ดับ
ไม่ดับเรียนมีที่รักกอล์ฟเปล่าแล้วเทียน
ดับแบบนึงไม่ดับใช้พัดพัด
เทียนไม่ดับๆ
สุด
ท้ายค่ะได้ยินได้ยินเสียงเสียงฟ้าของคุณ
ต้อมละที่เสียงดังมากได้ยินท่านี้ค่ะคือ
เค้กครั้งต่อไปนะคะก้าวต่อไปก็จะ
กินเคแล้วทีนี้ก็ดีใจด้วย
ให้ตัวเองนักเรียนมีเค้กวันเกิดครั้งล่า
สุดเมื่อไหร่กล่องน่าจะสุดท้ายละ
ไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีเพราะว่าไม่มีคนกิน
กูเอ๋โทรมาได้นะเดี๋ยวคุณต้องไปกินเออเออ
โอเคได้
โอเคค่ะครูเอ๋อันนี้วันเกิด
ไม่ต้องอายนะมันรู้ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็
รู้จักเกี่ยวกับอ่ะคนไทยก็จะมีแบบมีงาน
วันเกิดกับไม่มีงานวันเกิดนะคะก็จะมี 2
แบบนะคะวันเกิดอาจจะมีเค้กวันเกิดอาจจะทำ
บุญนะคะแล้วก็รู้จักครั้งล่าสุดครั้งสุด
ท้ายว่าเหมือนหรือไม่เหมือนกันยังไงนะคะ
แล้ววันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วใช่มั้ยคุณต้องหมด
เวลาแล้วค่ะจะตอบสะกิดในไหมคะได้ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันนะคะ Pop
อุ้ยถ้าก็หมดเวลาแล้วแต่ว่าเจอกันคลิป
หน้าหน้าครั้งต่อไปไม่ใช่ครั้งสุดท้ายใช่
มั้ยยังค่ะไม่ใช่ครั้งสุดท้ายไม่ช่างไม่
ใช่ยังไม่ครั้งต่อไปถ้านักเรียนอยากฟัง
คุณต้องอีกกดไลค์
รัวเลยค่ะ
โอเคค่ะขอบคุณค่ะคุณต้อมขอบคุณค่ะกูเอง
ขอบคุณค่ะนักเรียนไปบายนะคะ